Yes please, applause.
Thank you! My money's on Susan by the way,
if you're duking it out. But so boy I
okay my name's Ben Wiehe, I'll start
there. I work at the MIT Museum and my
title, my job title is manager of the
Science Festival Alliance. That's been my
job title since 2009.
It's hard to I kind of want to like just
cede my time to Lou because you know I
found it fantastic to listen her. I have
deep respect for her. I have worked see you
know I've been adjacent to her for a
while now
and she knows things and I don't know
that I'm not sure that's why I was asked
to stand in front of you. Because when
when Lou speaks about this you know she
has answers for your questions and I
think I'm just here to be sort of like
the curmudgeon who says it's a hot mess,
don't do it. So I have like four
different versions of what I was going
to say. I've really struggled with this
because it's sort of been my life for
quite a while to be near the center of
gravity of something that looks like I
wouldn't call it community practice. It's
called the Science Festival Alliance. We
were intentional with that name so so I
have either not much to say or just way
too much.
Quick quick so basically I have come
down to just like well then I'll just
make it all about me so I'm gonna just
tell you a little bit about my
trajectory as the Science Alliance
manager, my perspective on the
practicalities which i think is like the
code for like the hard parts and the
messy parts. So the Science Festival Alliance started as a with an NSF grant so we
came out of the gates with a concept
that was around a particular format of a
festival for the I'm not going to get
into what festivals are etc they're of,
for, by the community. They're massive
celebrations regional celebrations of
science. If you've ever
been to any festival think of that, now make
it for science. We had some we had this
clear format. We had a three million
dollar grant. We had the structure was
already there who was going to be
working on this they we had somebody
with a job title that was supposedly
gonna manage the Alliance part. We had
these guiding principles but they
weren't very prescriptive; it was meant
to be open-ended. You know every
community needs to figure out what it is
to celebrate science, so it wasn't about
stamping out a product. We had multiple
full-time equivalents working on the
project at four different institutions.
We had big travel budgets and meeting
budgets. Even with all of this I remember
being I just feeling so under-resourced
which sounds ridiculous you know three
million dollars and all these people
working on these incredible institutions
with advocates at the highest echelons
of science. But we've assembled we
quickly assemble the machine to get
three festivals up and running:
Philadelphia, San Diego, San Francisco, but
others were already wanting in or at
least they thought they did. They're kind
of in some we still have this challenge
of like we're not science fairs we're
science festivals. That was like even
that is where we should were starting.
Those early years were all consuming.
That's a phrase I was like well if I was
to sum it up it was all consuming. I just
felt like we had a very brief
window of opportunity. We had the
potential of this attention seizing
moment, we had this three-year grant,
I was hired six months and it had
already bled out six months when I
was hired and ostensibly the thing
started, so I and a few others just threw
ourselves completely into this in a
frenzy and I remember thinking this is
insane! Why am I at the White House right
now? What is that? What is happening?
We we're building something and once
it's built then we're gonna have this
thing and we're gonna be able to do so
many exciting things with it.
So at the end of three years we had done
something right. We had we had something
like a dozen festivals that we could
count as sort
being in the fold whatever that meant, we
had done our best to maximize attention,
we had you know like New York Times
coverage, USA Today, we had incredible
images from the festivals so we had this
like repository to help tell our
story. We had eyebrow-raising evaluation
results and we had eye watering
anecdotes; just the most touching, moving,
passionate stories and we had zeal. We
were zealots about this but even with
all that like suddenly I'm faced with
like the most uncertain time. Were the
festival is going to continue to be of
interest? What was going on? Is this just
some like weird passing fad? Would the
best support for them be to like really
pour effort into like building out a
network or community practice or
whatever? But is this thing -
and oh by the way that funding clock is
really close to alarm bells going off,
meaning and when that goes off the whole
thing just unravels. Okay so we need to
get, yeah so we need to get the funding.
Who would get that funding? Where would
it come from? And we didn't really talk
about it much but underlying all this
who owns this thing anyways? Put that
aside don't deal with that. So 2012 after
all this effort and throwing not just
myself but several people putting all
they had into this, it was a very
difficult year. While it was supposed to
be crowning like we've done this like
high fives all around, there are so many
meetings as we tried to sort out
internally what the Science Festival
Alliance was, what it should be, how to
realistically make the most of its
potential. Key personnel were leaving,
some personalities were proving
problematic and needed to be I'll say
managed out. It's so hard for, I'm kind of
a nice guy, I don't know. I'm not
conflict averse but it's just I you know
I don't want to tell you but yes. The the
amazing relationships that we built up
were growing precarious and you know one
little learning point, the best
relationships are created under extreme
duress. And we had gone through that
Crucible there but these were people who
are very action-oriented, all about
taking action on a grand grand scale
and they all had except for me festivals
of their own churching away. Like they're
like hey we've got 40,000 people coming
to this location
next Sunday so like sitting down to talk
about what the Science Festival Alliance
might be and where we might be headed as
a group don't really have time for that
and so your meetings are becoming a
little bit boring and and you know I was
I remember worrying that I was losing
traction as a manager if I even was a
manager and that the whole thing was
really you know it's coming possibly to
loose ends. I distinctly remember
thinking, and maybe this is a Lou moment,
that the problem was at that time our
real constraints were forcing a top-down
approach to issues that would be much
better addressed from the bottom up and
part of that was a draft after a draft
after a draft of a potential NSF bid was
piling up on my desk. We had these
competing visions. We tried putting
working committees in place. We tried to
I think the uncertainty made some people
anxious enough we try to formalize
things with strategic plans a membership
program but this just led to more items
needing consensus. Consensus sometimes is
lowest common denominator. One person
even went so far as to draft a
constitution that would govern the
Science Festival Alliance. I mean we're
just kind of like grasping at these
things. I found an old file cabinet on
campus and dragged it physically down
the sidewalk to my office to put next to
my desk which was a door that I had
flipped over on its side in 2009 because
I only had three years here anyways.
Through all this, the phone calls with
festivals are still going on. New
festival organizers really want to
talk about these conversations that we
had three years ago and the older
festival organizers have completely new
set of issues that they want to talk
about and in the midst of all this I
find myself going to Cairo with state
department funding that
supposed to be generating a Science
Festival Alliance in the Middle East
during the Arab Spring and I'm like what
why did that happen? Well because you
know because they're there basically I
couldn't let any opportunity go by. Like
I had to seize everything. All right well
we got the NSF grant. We asked for three
million they said two. So that was a little
bit painful because we worked on this
thing. We didn't just put three in
because it was a cap. We wanted more! At
the same time we got our first major
grant from a private foundation.
I hired Julie Foucher and I built her a
desk in similar style to mine because
we only could count on having her for
two years but now things this is all
looks like really good news right I mean
now 2012
well that was painful but boy 2013 this
is gonna be amazing. Except there's no
excuses, the funding clocks even tighter
now and I mean basically it's just like
alright well now it's time to throw
everything I have into this project
again like I was just doing I'm just
gonna up that. I felt like I'd never
been busier. We went from 11 festivals to
30 in a year's time and we put a real
membership thing in place. It was light
and I don't know if it makes everybody
happy but we have it. The new members
have like a really different needs than
the old guard of festivals that have been
around for a whole two or three years and
we had staff at eight institutions
around the country remunerated in some
way to work on this network which you
think is incredible. It really was so
heartening to see people do this
especially because like ask the you know
I'm just gonna do that air quote thing sorry
"manager" of this that I was my job title
mmm but I mean none of these people
actually reported to me or to anyone
else that was responsible in some way
for the project so soft power is all I
had and I don't know that that could
even be call it that. So as things grow
at this crazy pace, it layers up
different expectations of how I should
be spending my time. I had to go silent
on some relationships simply out of like
saying like I have to rely on that to be
there and soon I had people saying what
do you even do anymore? I'm like I've
been so busy that's why we haven't
talked but I realized that I was not you
know not documenting sufficiently not
getting you know there there's these
these shortfalls as it just piled up and
became overwhelming. And now we're like 8
million dollars later, going into our
10th year, and we've involved we've
evolved in so many ways and festivals
like I don't have to explain that
they're not science fairs anymore. I mean
we achieved that and the things that
I've seen like and now my burden is in
part like I want to grab everybody by
the lapels and be like "do you know what's
happened out there" because we haven't as
much as we've tried to capture it it we
never really you know can convey this
heart moving experiences that are
happening in communities across the
United States. It seems like we've
you know we we recently had a just last
weekend had a lunch with a couple people
and we were just congratulating
ourselves rightly so because just kind
of tried to take a moment to do that and
well later that afternoon I got
some, my phone's ringing right now, but
like later that afternoon like I got
these I got a couple emails from two
festivals that were like worried about
the the behavior of another festival and
the next day I had two financial reports
due and those are now overdue and I also
was laying out the application process
to bring 12 new festivals into the
network and I was just like wow we're I'm
right back where I remember thinking to
myself
I'm at this spot I've got like two or
three years of funding right now and I
just need to throw everything I have
into this next window of opportunity
where like because now is the time when
like that these things are we're gonna
build something at the end of this three
years it's gonna be so incredible. So I
think I'll just leave it at that
that's a practice.
I don't know if that's helpful to anyone.
Hi Ben. You know I know you
You've watched this insanity unfold.
So one of the things that just sounds so
familiar and I'm sure it is to Jeanne
and a bunch of people is like where we
have good examples of communities of
practice or organizations it often feels
like there is one or a small number of
individuals who are basically like
burning the candle at six ends and
they're soon gonna drop down and have a
heart attack or in practice what
actually happens is...
My doctor says it's because my three-year-olds really heavy and it's like muscle it's not my heart.
Yep. So I'm okay. My doctor just laughs. But so in fact people don't have heart
attacks people as you said they leave
because it's totally dynamic yeah always
changing um so I guess, partly for
you partly for Lou, like what happens
when people suddenly decide they don't
want to die at 34 from well cardiac arrest?
Well, I'm not so, I'm pretty okay with like putting my ego aside on this. Like I don't think
that I'm the essential ingredient that
makes all anything happen as I say all
this not only just anything at all but
there are key moments in the development
of this where I felt okay I like my job
I just want to say that I do and and I'm
really I love the experience that I've
had over the past 10 years with this
project and there are other projects
that I also work on which is you know
that's another thing is that many of the
people involved in this that are you're
totally depending on it's completely not
their job at all. But I definitely have
felt like there are many many moments
where I felt like trapped a little bit.
Not trapped in uh like I want to get out
but like oh if I did want to get out I'm
not sure I could without things kind of
feeling like they might implode a little
bit. I don't know how to reinforce that.
We've put together these you know at
various times when the anxiety built and
was really palpable we put together
different kinds of structures to deal
with it at that moment; most recently
there was a Science Festival Alliance
Council and I thought if I call it a
council not a committee it would feel
like something that you know had more
responsibility and people are
enthusiastic about it, but it's sort of
like you know it served a purpose for a
couple years and then like we had our
summit in this past June and we decided
yeah we don't really need to meet the
council that you know I think we did
that served its purpose. So I you just
kind of like create organizational structures for the demands of the
moment and the demands at the moment can be really fleeting. I'm glad we didn't
adopt the Constitution. Essentially if
you do end up successfully building a
I would say so and echo the first thing that Ben said, which is that
essentially, if you do end up successfully building a
community, the idea is that the roles and
responsibilities are shared. You know if
we actually build this together no one
person ought to be the weakest link.
We think about this a lot from the
perspective of community management so I
didn't mention this in my talk but after
you know when we set up these
communities there is somebody who is
designated in that role of coalescing
folks together, greasing the wheels,
ensuring you know that we remember to
reconvene, that we do the things that we
do and that role evolves over time. You
know, if your community is healthy
and it's actually progressing through a
life cycle and through to stages of
maturity, then the pressure should ease
on that community manager and yes
they're still doing a job but everything
should you know the success or failure
of that community should not depend on
the people convening it solely. And another thing that this gets at that I just
also want us to bear in mind, this echoes
what Jeanne was saying earlier about
acknowledging all the support staff that
makes things happen, this this role of
convening communities is a is an
invisible leadership role right. It's not
about one person or a group of people
standing up and saying hey here's what I
think we should do and we're gonna be
the ones that make sure it all gets done
all the time and so you know everybody
being aware of the fact that there there
is value being created there even if
this is not leadership in a very
front-and-center way I think is
important.
It might be helpful to point out that I don't I mean I do often
times quip that I don't do anything and
by that I mean I don't actually organize
a festival of myself. I don't have skin
in that game. My job is to, not like some
godlike figure, but like pull myself up
out and look over out across the
landscape so I have some feeling for
where the center of gravity of the group
be and I can look after those that like
aren't maybe aren't don't have the same
power in the in the community.
Kishore can tell the same story.
I know this story well. Hi, I'm Kishore. I get that it was hard.
I know it was hard because I was in some
of those stories you were telling.
I did not make that constitution. I did not. I was not part of the constitution. I vetoed the constitution.
We're aligned in that.
I get that it was really hard. Was it worth it?
Yeah absolutely I mean it's worth it
even in the even at moments when I
thought it was all gonna collapse
because of something some foolish thing
that I had neglected. It was still worth it.
Yeah absolutely. I mean it's it really
helps that we all work in a field that
is so inspiring. I mean it's just
inspiring. The product, our product is
inspiring if it's it ought to be and so
that really helps I mean the festivals
are absolutely amazing
and the thing that yeah so I could talk
about that I think that that's in the
end like I mean it's just there's this
like infinite wellspring of passion for
just keeping this going and spreading it
because it's so inspiring to me.
It's not a question, it's probably not a comment,
but listening to you, when you said you had a hard time,
it just made the feelings that I was
getting in the last couple of days even deeper. Most of
us are working in much smaller programs
and of how this this weekend of great
gorgeous programs they will all die when
the guy who
or women who's doing it will leave. They
can't even have advice person to do it
because they don't have funding. They put
their heart and soul into it
and as soon as they leave it will die. In
your story which is a great success
story it's just making it even more
apparent is it if you don't have an
organization of 12 people and you don't
have funding and you put in your summer
salary into doing the summer camp it's
gonna die when you leave and how how do
we make it sustainable? I've got so many
problems that were just well dying.
Well, I mean partly it is also just sort of isn't the also the nature of everything that we do
is is just very fleeting like I mean and dynamic? Isn't like it this
work it just never will never end is
another way to flip that around.
Well the festivals I mean we've been
very lucky but the festival is not
exactly brick-and-mortar. They can just
did not a year goes by when I'm not
having a crisis conversation with some
festival organizer about like I don't
know if how we're gonna do it this year.
So I it I think there's something about
like this for example this meeting, I
know a lot of people that are here. I've met a
lot of people. I've had a lot of
inspiring conversations and great
conversations here. I there's not been
enough time. I wish that this will keep
going. But at the same time a lot of the
conversations here mirror conversations
I've had at other meanings. This is the
fourth meeting I've been to in two weeks
and and I've seen a lot of people at
this meeting at those other meetings
those other meetings are helpful but
this why would this meet again well
because we continue to have we live in a
dynamic situation with new members can
come and go the issues that the
community's trying to address are going
to continually be evolving so it's it's
sort of like you know I've just coming
to peace with the knowledge that like
I'm not a construction worker. Like I
don't build a building and then go like
right there it is and that's gonna last
there for generations or 35 years is the
current standard actually. But so we
work in a different like softer, are the
product of our work is this softer than
that and it just needs constant
attention so if a program dies I I don't
sorry I couldn't hear that
There's also part of me that
like is another side to that - sorry
just like keep finding silver linings or
way to reframe that positively - is now I'm no longer
a curmudgeon - is that the if you look at
our historical I mean if taking a more
historical stance on the world would do
the entire United States a world of good.
So looking just a little bit back, you
can see first of all you can see
enormous improvement and evolution in
positive directions. But you can also
just like talk to a real old timer and
you start to hear like oh yeah that's
just like that thing we did in 1984 and
that thing in there was member that in
the 70s we had this other program that
that was just so amazing and so you know
with the festivals people there's some
people get really fixated on origin
stories especially those who think that
they are the origin and part of my job
is to poke holes in that. I actually
it's not my job it's my personality is
its to poke holes in those kinds of that
notion because you know my god where the
science festivals come from who started
this thing and my reply is not meant to
be facetious but like I say I kind of
peg it to like maybe dawn of agriculture.
To put it there comfortably that like
people have been coming together to
celebrate how technology and knowledge
makes them who they are. That's let's put
it let's put it you know there's like
World's Fairs and all that but I just go
way back this is and it's a natural
human endeavor this is. We've been doing
this for forever.
Hi, I'm Amanda Smith. I was asked to speak about 100k in 10. First of all, I'm from
Penn State's Center for Science in the
schools and I'm the representative for
the university and 100k in 10, if
you're not aware of it, is an or national
organization that has about two hundred
and fifty members of it so far and
they're always growing but they have a
really nice structure where they've
divided into project teams to tackle
varying issues across STEM education and
outreach. Talia, the CEO, was supposed
to be here today but couldn't be, but if
you'd like to find out more information
I'm always happy to share it on the
Slack channel and give you more
information. But the structure is really
nice because it can't just take one
person to manage all of it. It's going to
take a village and how they've divided
project teams has been really really
nice and they've spent a lot of time
mapping out the Grand Challenges in STEM
education and it's it's public now and
it's called I believe it's called like
grandchallenges.100kin10.org but
they're really looking at all the issues
of getting highly qualified over a
hundred thousand qualified STEM ready
educators by the next ten years and so
2022 is the date that they're up and
they were originally funded by the Obama
administration and the Clinton
initiative also funds them heavily as
well. But I think it's a definitely a
great organization to look at as far as
structure and how we might be able to
fold in and to learn more about those
Grand Challenges and maybe where does
science outreach also fold into that
dynamic as well.